quando ho preso per la prima volta la
patente e quindi ho cominciato a guidare
l'automobile di casa mi sono accorto che
lo spazio che avevamo il nostro posto
auto era particolarmente angusto ecco un
po più angusto di così però simile alla
macchina che vediamo in queste immagini
mi sono trovato di fronte la decisione
parcheggio in retromarcia o parcheggio
di punta in questo foto vediamo alcune
macchine parcheggiate in retromarcia e
altre viceversa perché questo mi ha
fatto accorgere subito che mentre tutti
i miei familiari parcheggiavano di punta
io ero l'unico a parcheggiare in
retromarcia cioè mi occupavo di fare una
manovra per loro una manovra che a loro
non interessava perché tanto sapevano
che non era detto che sarebbero stati
loro i primi a riprendere l'automobile
quindi lasciavano la manovra
qualcun'altro and ice mi capitava di
lasciare la macchina pronta a uscire è
invece toccava a farla sia quando
parcheggiavo sia quando mi toccava
uscire dopo un po mi rese conto che
questa cosa era difficilmente verbalizza
bill e cioè non potevo sapere se ero io
nel giusto se erano loro nel giusto e
quindi mi semplicemente mi sono abituato
a loro modo di fare quando però dopo
poco tempo ho iniziato a vivere con
quella che è la mia attuale moglie ho
sperato che quello potesse essere un
nuovo inizio e quindi ho detto ha
finalmente avrò una persona con cui
passare di gres la mia vita una persona
che parcheggerà in retromarcia perché
sarà così felice di trovare la macchina
pronta per farmi uscire e io sarò
felicissimo di trovare la macchina
pronta
avrete già capito che anche mia moglie
parcheggiava di punta e quindi di nuovo
mi sono trovato nella stessa situazione
e non riuscivo a capire ancora se era un
mio errore o sera in effetti lei dalla
parte della ragione che semplicemente
parcheggiare di punta è la soluzione
ottimale
poi per fortuna una volta su un giornale
ho trovato una donna un mondo
non ricordo comunque un'altra coppia che
scriveva a un economista e gli chiedeva
esattamente di questo problema gli
chiedeva conviene parcheggiare di punto
conviene parcheggiare in retromarcia e
questo è l'economista team orford
rispondeva molto semplicemente guarda la
cosa per me più importante la teoria
economica classica e la teoria economica
classica prevede che il piacere deve
essere immediato quindi fa bene chi
parcheggia di punta perché l'altra è una
cosa che resta i posteri e i posteri bo
ci possiamo dividere interessare di loro
dopo tutto cosa hanno fatto questi
posteri per noi lo diceva anche orazio e
io però pensavo di essere io il i
posteri rispetto a mia moglie ma
comunque fatto sta che per la teoria
economica questa era la soluzione giusta
parcheggiare di punta e in effetti che
l'economia ragioni in questo modo lo
vediamo da situazioni ben più enormi lo
vediamo che quando ad esempio ci
occupiamo del petrolio quando sentiamo
del surriscaldamento climatico
sono tutte questioni che si ce ne
occupiamo però fondamentalmente lasciamo
agli altri cioè qualcuno le riforme era
al posto nostro
uno dei più grandi economisti del secolo
anche un premio nobel peter schelling
analizzato quanto le macro la
macroeconomia sia mossa dalle micro
motivazioni delle persone cioè quanto
tutte le cose del le guerre le
catastrofi i mutamenti geopolitici
dipendano molto spesso da motivazioni
piccole
quello però che a me interessa nel caso
specifico nel caso del parcheggio non è
time invece notare quanto la
macroeconomia riguardi anche le nostre
piccole scelte cioè che io possa far
decidere di parcheggiare la mia
automobile di punta all retromarcia non
copiato e copiando quelle che sono le
decisioni appunto sul surriscaldamento
climatico
io sono un appassionato di questo tipo
di quesiti filosofici in questa
guardiamo prima quello di destra
lì c'è un treno e inarrestabile un treno
rotto inarrestabile
andrebbe a uccidere le cinque persone
che sono legate sui binari
lì c'è un'altra persona che ha a
disposizione una leva e può con quella
leva spostare deviare il treno e
lanciarlo su cui l'unica persona c'è un
quesito morale abbastanza questo forse
il più celebre di questi in cui si
chiede è legittimo per quella persona
girarla leva e uccidere una persona
rispetto a 5
molto spesso le persone considerano oggi
che sia legittimo perché uno è
preferibile a 5
c'è però il caso ulteriore di questo qui
a sinistra in cui la soluzione
leggermente diversa cioè ci si chiede se
è legittimo spingere quella persona
corpulenta sui binari in modo tale da
fermare il treno è così da evitare che
il treno uccida anche gli altri cinque
ora al di là della questione di
filosofia morale che è fondamentalmente
irrisolta
a me piace di questa storia il fatto che
tutti i filosofi moderni e tutti i
filosofi contemporanei si concentrano
sul dato statistico cioè soldato che
sono cinque persone rispetto a una
mentre per i filosofi classici ma ancora
per il filosofo fino all'ottocento
questo non era il tema centrale cioè il
tema centrale era è legittimo muovere
quella leva è legittimo spingere una
persona e decidere di ucciderla oppure
quella persona eccoli l'unico legato è
diverso da quello lì nel momento in cui
io agisco sulla leva o io agisco
spingendo lui
questo per me è la dimostrazione
ulteriore del fatto che l'economia cioè
la possibilità di scambiare di di
contare enumerare le cose ha preso per
certi versi anche il sopravvento sul
nostro modo di relazionarci anche a
questioni più piccole tuttavia allo
stesso tempo ci ha dato
il pensiero economico e anche la teoria
economica più semplice che spiegavo
prima la possibilità di relazionarci una
quantità enormi di scelte noi rispetto a
anche gli stessi cittadini di qualche
anno fa abbia una possibilità enormi di
scegliere di agire in uno dei miei
romanzi preferiti le correzioni di
jonathan franzen si racconta uno dei
personaggi decide di tornare dai paesi
baltici dove si era trasferito decide di
tornare nel proprio paese negli stati
uniti una volta in un supermercato non
si trova in un supermercato deve
comprare qualcosa come un dentifricio e
li vede che la scelta di quel
supermercato lì nei paesi baltici
estremamente limitata allora mi viene
una nostalgia terribile degli stati
uniti di quegli scaffali enormi dove
poteva scegliere tra 40 magari tra
centinaia di prodotti forse simili
semplicemente con un packaging diverso
eppure quello per lui è la forma
talmente importante del la scelta la
possibilità di scegliere è talmente
connaturato a se stesso che proprio
parte di sé
ora nella oggi parliamo proprio proposte
della possibilità di scegliere si parla
molto spesso di switching economy cioè
la possibilità di cambiare possiamo
sceglierci i nostri fornitori di servizi
nel maniere più incredibile possiamo
sceglie il nostro fornitore di servizi
per il telefono ma ormai possiamo
cambiarlo anche per il fornitore del gas
il fornitore dell'elettricità e ci
troviamo molto spesso a cambiarlo non a
caso appunto diciamo di switch economy
tuttavia le stesse persone che a cui
capita di cambiare che molto spesso
cambiano per motivi è solamente
economici perché per cosa altro dovremmo
cambiare il nostro operatore telefonico
se non per risparmiare
quando poi negli stessi sondaggi si va a
chiedere se il vecchio
fornitore di servizi avrebbe potuto fare
qualcosa per tenerli legati a se si
trovano a rispondere che sì nell'ottanta
per cento dei casi dicono sì il nostro
il mio vecchio fornitore avrebbe potuto
fare qualcosa per tenermi legate 6
qualcosa
questo per me è un esempio fondamentale
del fatto che anche al massimo della
possibilità di scelta cioè che ci offre
l'economia quello di cambiare in
qualsiasi genere di operatore c'è
qualcosa che ci manca e si avverte
questa mancanza
all'apice del della possibilità c'è
questa mancanza di dire sì però ci
potrebbe essere qualche altra cosa
molto spesso i fornitori di servizi
quando si trovano essere abbandonati si
appellano a certi scrupoli morali a cui
poi non si erano appellati nel momento
in cui offrivano il servizio qualche
angolo circa un anno fa
io mi sono trovato a dover abbandonare
l'abbonamento a una delle mie riviste
preferite il new yorker
la prima cosa che ha fatto la rivista è
stata dirmi no guarda che se tu resti
ancora abbonato con noi resta ancora con
noi ti facciamo uno sconto ma vedendo
che a me dello scontro non interessava
un gran che sono passati a un genere di
attacco che puntava sui sensi di colpa
di qualsiasi tipo ed erano sensi di
colpa di un abbandono come di un
abbandono del tetto coniugale come un
abbandono della parola non erano sensi
di colpa legati erano abbandono di una
offerta economica migliore e quindi mi
arrivavano foto della redazione mi
arrivavano cartoline personalizzate e io
mi sentivo in colpa
avrei voluto guardate che io non sono
cambiato perché loro mi accusano di
essere cambiate di essere diventato
cinico di non credere più alle cose
belle che avevano fatto per me
ha tutto quello che avevano creato
eppure io l'ho abbandonato e non per
la questione ma quando ho visto che mi
hanno spinto tutti questi scrupoli
morali che forse l'ho abbandonato anche
più volentieri questo però questa
necessità di cercare questo genere di
scrupoli vi ha fatto venire anche in
mente che forse il fornitore di servizi
più importante che abbiamo e il
matrimonio e ai fornitori di servizi per
per secoli è stato anche l'unico
fornitore di servizi
ora qualcuno sorride però in effetti era
anche l'unico contratto che per secoli
le persone hanno potuto scegliere cioè
si fa c'era un contratto che potrei fare
nella tua vita e dove farlo veramente
bene perché quella persona
immaginate di dover scegliere oggi un
operatore telefonico e dirlo per tutta
la vita ecco lì si fornivano qualsiasi
servizio era fornito allo stesso modo e
verrà fornito attraverso il matrimonio
non a caso oggi dal mio punto di vista
il matrimonio in crisi proprio perché è
in crisi questa idea che si è legata ai
servizi quando delle persone chiedono di
avere accesso al matrimonio o
addirittura a certe persone sono
costrette o decidono di divorziare per
rinunciare a dei diritti e di guadagnare
magari anche fiscalmente fanno perché
trattano il matrimonio di nuovo come uno
di questi contratti
parlavamo prima eppure perché fanno
coincidere per certi versi anche quello
che per noi è semplicemente la stessa
cosa cioè l'amore coincide col
matrimonio il in un libro molto recente
il professore di estetica bozza racconta
che questa la nostra idea che il
matrimonio sia legata fondamentalmente
all'amore dipende dal lech dal fatto che
tutta la tradizione occidentale ha
sempre legato
l'amore è un'idea fantasmatica dalle
persone amato cioè abbiamo sempre legato
l'idea che la persona amata fosse
idealizzata che sia fosse un uomo che
fosse una donna e non al fatto che in
realtà l'amore e quindi il matrimonio
dovessere essere di conseguenza un
semplice scambio reciproco di diritti e
doveri
questa cosa mi ha fatto pensare di nuovo
al problema del parcheggio perché mi
sono detto se semplicemente uno scambio
reciproco dei diritti e doveri
io sono assolutamente in diritto di
chiedere a qualcuno di parcheggiare così
come lui e di parcheggiare come voglio
io così come lui è in dovere di dover
rispondere la mia idea di parcheggio
eppure anche questo è dimostrato che
mancava una cosa ed è questo che la
parte che secondo me più interessante
della vicenda cioè il fatto che anche
nei momenti in cui vogliamo credere che
che l'economia possa essere in grado di
gestire anche le scelte più piccole o le
scelte più grandi della nostra vita c'è
sempre qualcosa che ci viene a mancare
allora siamo costretti a trovarla in un
altro modo e io ho pensato di trovarla
in un codice forse semplicemente
trovando questo codici si può trovare
tra due persone
l'idea di un rapporto che sia reciproco
davvero ma che non manchi di una che che
contenga allo stesso tempo questa radice
economica grazie